the last 24 hours have been some of the
busiest in news that I can remember for
a very long time starting with the
release of the whistleblower complaint
that is at the heart of the reason why
there is now an impeachment inquiry
against Donald Trump starting in the
House of Representatives this is the
whistleblower complaint that made the
original allegations that Donald Trump
was withholding hundreds of millions of
dollars in aid from Ukraine if and until
such time that Ukraine smears Joe Biden
for the benefit of Donald Trump in the
2020 election on the presumption that
Joe Biden is likely to be at least
according to Trump his challenger in the
2020 election we have seen suppression
of the whistleblower report we have seen
a quote transcript that is actually a
summary which we will talk about we have
seen the impeachment inquiry get going
so all of this stuff stems from the
whistleblower complaint that started at
all it has been released and it is
absolutely devastating to Donald Trump
and completely justifies that there is
now an impeachment inquiry whether the
impeachment inquiry is being handled
correctly by Democrats is a different
question which I'll get to later in the
show preview my thought is Democrats are
already blowing the impeachment inquiry
but we will get to that what is in the
whistleblower complaint the summary of
it the key points as I read them are
number one the whistleblower says Donald
Trump is using the office of the
presidency to solicit interference from
foreign powers to help him win 2020 with
the involvement of both Rudy Giuliani
his personal attorney and Attorney
General William bar the complaint is
based on the reports of more than six US
officials speaking to the whistleblower
who as of right this second is still
maintaining anonymity and we will see if
by the time you hear this the
whistleblower has not been named I fear
for the whistleblowers life if they are
no longer anonymous the details in the
whistleblower report about the Ukraine
call are basically as we already know
them I mean that's not a surprise that's
the part that was widely reported
earlier this week we've been talking
about it all
week it was partially the catalyst for
the impeachment inquiry against Donald
Trump and nothing surprising in the
whistleblower complaint about the
content of the call it coincides
perfectly with what's been reported all
week long
White House officials according to this
report already knew what was going on
with Ukraine before the phone call took
place and they were immediately working
after the phone call on various methods
to cover-up the content of the call some
of which we have since learned about
some of which involve different email
servers shockingly I thought it was
Hillary that we had to worry about the
whistleblower says that about a dozen
different people listened to the phone
call in question on July 25th between
Donald Trump and the Ukrainian president
the records of the call were immediately
quote locked down according to the
whistleblower including the actual
transcript which exists to this report
this is important to understand Donald
Trump ultimately released a summary of
the call not a transcript of the call
which we will get to the actual
transcript does exist and this of course
suggests that they knew all along the
importance of covering up the actual
full records of what was said during the
phone call White House lawyers
reportedly went to White House officials
and said remove the electronic
transcript and put it on to a different
computer system that allegedly took
place and we are going to talk about
that more in detail as well the
whistleblower complaint also says that
Rudy Giuliani has been traveling all
over the world to meet with different
Ukrainians including for example going
to Spain to meet with advisor to the
Ukrainian president Andriy your Mac or
your nak it's hard to actually tell the
MN looks a little hard to tell what it
is when you look at the PDF of the
complaint so what have we learned
additionally from the whistleblower
complaint we've learned about the moving
of the electronic records to different
servers which I'll get into detail next
we've learned that William Bar needs to
be completely separated from every
proceeding that is even remotely related
to this because he is named as one of
the players in this attempted twenty20
interference involving Ukraine he has to
recuse himself and it is stunning that
yet another of Donald Trump's Attorney
General's should recuse themselves from
one of the most important stories
involving the actions of the President
and unfortunately William Bar is
involved in a lot of this stuff because
he heads up the Justice Department so he
should immediately recuse himself will
he I have no idea and of course the
obvious conclusion from reading the
whistleblower complaint is that even if
even 15 percent of the report is
accurate the impeachment inquiry against
Donald Trump is 110 percent warranted so
now let's get into detail about the
separate computer system to which the
whistleblower alleges records of the
July 25 phone call between Trump and the
Ukrainian president were moved